[Music]
on this thursday night flooding
emergency
well this is pretty scary stuff
thousands forced to flee as a surge of
water and ice devastates a northern town
pretty tragic for the community i mean
it's obviously a sad day but it's also
frustrating for people that aren't here
plus the other communities facing
extreme weather damage
russia's war leads to nato expansion
there is a real threat here for
countries in europe two nordic nations
signal they want into the alliance as
the kremlin threatens retaliation
wrongly accused of poaching eagle
feathers they treated this like it was a
criminal act and it wasn't the
indigenous men seeking an apology over
their wrongful arrest and the milky way
monster the never-before-seen evidence
of what lies in the center of our galaxy
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is a range of extreme weather
across this country a heatwave in
central canada and catastrophic floods
devastating areas in the prairies and
the north this is the town of hay river
northwest territories it is largely
submerged by flood water an evacuation
order was triggered overnight for the
entire town on the edge of great slave
lake the territory says water levels
have risen 1.7 meters over the past
three days nearby in northern alberta
heavy rain and snowmelt have forced
people from their homes three
communities there are under local states
of emergency and in southern manitoba
overland flood warnings and watches are
in place as that saturated province
braces for even more rain
flooding isn't new of course but climate
scientists have found canada's north is
warming more than twice as fast as
regions further south and that's having
a profound impact on the environment and
on people's lives heather urex west has
our top story tonight
okay it's roughly four o'clock in the
morning and this is her crescent in hay
river an entire community home after
home battered by a frigid flood you can
see the water's coming up we had a major
push of ice and water and it ripped
through the town and came through
several areas of town that have never
seen water
so we've evacuated the whole community
we heard sirens going off there was
emergency alerts going off on our phone
marissa oteza had little time to gather
her young family together and go opting
to drive through the night to seek
shelter in yellowknife five hours away
as we were evacuating we could see the
water rushing into the neighborhoods
into people's houses and yards
it was kind of surreal from the air
thursday the devastation can be seen
with heartbreaking clarity the local
airport entirely underwater the
unprecedented flooding caused by the
one-two punch of a heavy snowpack melt
and a river jammed with breaking ice
it's pretty tragic for the community i
mean
it's obviously a sad day but it's also
frustrating for people that aren't here
and
you know they just want to be home but
the reality is
ultimately we don't have the
infrastructure
the town of 3500 is now assessing its
water treatment plant and sewage system
for damages caused by the flood there
have also been power interruptions and
there is likely to be more flooding
ahead as the ice continues to crack we
have a few kilometers of ice still to
deal with
so it's not really safe for most
residents to return there was a flood in
63
that wasn't this bad areas of the cat
ledeche first nation are underwater as
well
in total about 4 000 people have been
displaced with little to do now but
watch and wait
heather urex west global news
southern manitoba is in for another
downpour over the next few days
prompting that province to upgrade the
flood threat in some regions forecasters
are monitoring a system that's expected
to arrive late today that could bring an
additional 20 to 40 millimeters of rain
several manitoba communities are already
dealing with major flooding 28 of them
have declared states of local emergency
rain would be a welcome site in
california this is the latest update
from the u.s drought monitor nearly the
entire state is already under severe
drought conditions 60 percent of it is
in extreme drought that means there's
not enough water for wildlife
agriculture and urban needs
and all that has led to this overnight a
ferocious fire swept through part of
orange county south of los angeles about
20 multi-million dollar mansions in
laguna miguel could not be saved a
foreboding sign of the new normal the
blaze broke out in brush late yesterday
afternoon and fueled by powerful ocean
winds it raged across more than 80
hectares in just three hours officials
say there's no longer a fire season
it's all year long
now to russia's war in ukraine canada is
boosting its military presence in latvia
north of ukraine
we will be deploying a general and six
staff officers to nato's multinational
division north headquarters in adazi
ukraine latvia's prime minister was in
ottawa for meetings with prime minister
trudeau the seven canadians will be part
of a first of its kind unit in the
northern baltic sea region to help plan
coordinate and integrate regional
military activities canadian troops in
latvia are leading a battle group on
nato's eastern flank
russia's president wants to halt nato
expansion but his invasion of ukraine is
having the opposite effect today finland
russia's nordic neighbor announced it is
set to join the western military
alliance and sweden could be next
they're doing it to strengthen their own
security and almost immediately the
kremlin warned it would retaliate
jackson prosko won a big shift in
military alliances
with its 1300 kilometer long border with
russia a growing liability finland
abandoned neutrality and set course to
join nato blaming vladimir putin my
response would be that
you caused this
look at the mirror if finnish lawmakers
approve the country could be a full
member of the alliance within a year on
the streets of helsinki relief i think
it's a great thing because it will bring
more safety
to finland against russian aggression
it's absolutely that we should chain
nato
sweden is expected to follow suit
throwing up a further wall against an
unpredictable russia
the kremlin called nato's expansion a
threat and vowed to take what it called
necessary measures there is a real
threat here for countries in europe and
it's going to be a threat for the long
term so i think
finland and sweden are making the right
choice here until their membership
becomes official both countries remain
vulnerable unprotected by the mutual
defense of nato's article 5.
as a stop gap great britain signed
security agreements vowing to protect
both countries nato is a defensive
alliance nato poses nato poses no threat
to anyone
if vladimir putin sought to break
western unity his war in ukraine has
done the opposite
finland and sweden are on track to
rapidly ascend to nato both as an
insurance policy
and a show of resolve against russia
jackson prosko global news washington
it is day 78 of russia's invasion of
ukraine today unicef confirmed nearly
100 children were killed in april alone
and the actual figures could be much
higher those lucky enough to escape the
fighting in marijuana have made it to
zaparosia yesterday nearly 370 people
arrived leaving behind death destruction
and relentless shelling
our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing spoke with some of them
plotting an escape in a car nearly
totaled by shelling what sure what this
mother did everything she could think of
to make her vehicle appear
non-threatening to the occupying
russians white strips of fabric on the
door handles symbols of peace and a sign
that says children written in russian
if i stay longer i may have lost my car
how could i leave then so we ran away
valentina shows me a video on her phone
of what used to be her apartment in
mariupol she and her two-year-old son
weren't there when it was destroyed
they've spent the past two months
running basement to basement apartment
to apartment their last hiding place
became home to about 300 people
maliki he's too young and i hope he will
not remember those terrible events
daniel may not but yuri certainly does
he says i already lived under occupation
once it was in 1941 i no longer want to
live under the occupiers again
at 94 his hearing is poor and so is his
health his daughter svetlana helps us
communicate with him she says he
understands what they're going through
they won't run away from a good man once
a hotel this building is housing 130
refugees yuri is the oldest
since russia invaded 2 000 others have
sought shelter here it's quiet and kept
dimly lit for safety
safety and small comforts don't erase
heartbreak the pain of leaving home is
immense for people here on their first
day and months later
ilana andriy and their teenage daughter
and his parents all escaped together his
furniture shop in mariopol like almost
everything else
destroyed you could get insurance we had
two floors in the building and all of
these lawns
the loans still remain people here say
they won't go home unless they know
they'll be living under a ukrainian flag
and in the southeast
that's far from certain
crystal gavinson global news zaparizia
ukraine
organizing a political debate with
multiple candidates can be challenging
and last night's debate between six
people running for the federal tory
leadership got mixed reviews party
members have to choose one of the
candidates so did they get anything out
of it our chief political correspondent
david aiken tuned in and is with us from
edmonton david
well donna this was the first debate to
feature all six candidates patrick brown
the mayor of brampton ontario making his
debate debut
mr brown
my vision of canada includes a
conservative party that builds a broad
multi-faith multicultural coalition that
can win but it's not clear brown had
much of an impact he should have gone
back to selling memberships that's what
he does well
he did not look good on on the stage
perceived front-runner pierre pauliev
made waves promising to fire bank of
canada governor tiff macklin the bank of
canada governor has allowed himself to
become the atm machine of this
government
and so i would replace him with a new
governor
economists say if pauliev was ever to
make good on such a threat and it's not
clear that he could that would actually
hurt the economy international investors
get spooked uh they start pulling their
money out of a country in which case you
know would put a run on the canadian
dollar where everybody was trying to
sell canadian dollars and no one's
buying so you know that would be a bad
situation pauliev drew fire from almost
all his rivals for his enthusiastic
endorsement of digital cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin everyone just finds it
totally bizarre what mr poliev is
suggesting anyone following his advice
that we saw on youtube would have lost
20 percent of their earnings do you
actually think your parents enjoy having
your parents lose 20 of their retirement
funds i mean this is ludacy the debate
covered plenty of ground with candidates
quizzed on everything from abortion to
supply management to what they were
binge watching on netflix my
parliamentary colleague eric molillo got
me hooked on brooklyn 99 while we were
doing french immersion in quebec
it was that kind of night the next time
this group of six gets together is at
the end of the month may the 25th in
quebec for the only french language
debate and that comes right before the
june 3rd cut off to register to vote
when the race concludes in september
donna
all right david aiken thank you the
federal ndp leader jagmeet singh calls
what happened to him at a campaign stop
in peterborough ontario this week one of
the most intense threatening and
insulting experiences of his political
career
[Applause]
these videos posted on social media show
a small group harassing him yelling
vulgarities calling him a liar and a
traitor and saying he's not welcome all
this happened to singh walked from an
office to his vehicle
i've experienced a lot of this kind of
hatred and and being physically attacked
even when i was younger and i've learned
to defend myself i've taken martial arts
but that shouldn't be the requirement
that you've got to be physically fit and
skilled in defending yourself to be a
politician or leader that to me is
completely wrong and problematic
politicians of all stripes have reached
out to sing and condemned what happened
and the peterborough police service says
it's investigating
writing a wrong coming up the calls for
a public inquiry into the arrest of 13
indigenous men
eagle feathers are sacred to many
indigenous communities and they were at
the heart of a legal case in british
columbia 13 indigenous men were charged
with wildlife violations after dozens of
mutilated eagle carcasses were found
eventually the charges were dropped but
not before the men say their reputations
were damaged and as nithu garcia reports
they've been demanding an apology for
years
feathers that i'm wearing are
close to 100 years old but it would be
years before chief ralph leon of staelis
a first nations tribe in bc's lower
mainland could wear the sacred headdress
he earned the cultural right to use it
but says a probation order barred him
from using eagle feathers
chief leon who survived abuse in a
residential school was arrested and
strip searched when he his friend gary
abbott and 11 others were charged with
various wildlife act offenses in 2006
after nearly 50 mutilated eagle
carcasses were found in north vancouver
we had nothing to do with
with the findings of those birds
though they're sacred to us
almost a decade later in 2015 crown
council determined it no longer had
grounds to proceed and their charges
were dropped but not before the case
claimed many of their reputations
relationships and jobs teacher by trade
and i wasn't allowed to be that teacher
which i loved so much
nine years
we went and had to check in every week
for bail their lawyer argued the bc
conservation officer service used
inappropriate undercover tactics
attending indigenous cultural events
like powwows to gain trust bringing
alcohol onto the otherwise dry reserve
and luring the accused men into illegal
activity i don't want my children
or my grandchildren to have to go
through that
that's why we we were fighting this
their story is now the subject of a
petition tabled by bc conservative mp
brad viss in the house of commons this
week those wrongfully charged have
gathered sufficient evidence showcasing
a conspiracy to prosecute innocent
people b defamatory media release
vilifying indigenous peoples and
cultures see fabrication of evidence and
concealment of evidence including
perjury when asked about a public
inquiry justice minister david lametty
told global news he'll review the
petition i understand the importance of
eagles and eagle feathers
to their their tradition to their
ceremony and so we'll work to try to
find a solution these men are also
calling for the return of their seized
regalia things i learned from
residential school day school
conservation services taught me
something really valuable
how not to be they're also seeking an
apology with acknowledgement the
systemic efforts to make indigenous
culture criminal are not just a part of
canada's history but canada's present
nitu garcia global news vancouver
managing inflation ahead help navigating
canada's rising costs
there's no escaping sky-high inflation
it hits you everywhere from the gas
station to the grocery store in our new
series sticker shock ann gaviola has
some ideas on navigating life's rising
costs
and then we're gonna swing it was all
smiles when sandy young welcomed little
gabriel into the world last year but
every day there's a growing anxiety too
matt leave has meant bringing in less
money and the new baby also equals lots
of new spending on diapers a crib baby
food
our family definitely has been feeling
the pinch with inflation and the rising
cost of gas and groceries inflation
plunged at the start of the pandemic but
it moved back beyond two percent in
march 2021 and has been soaring since to
levels we haven't seen in more than
three decades
ipsos polling exclusively for global
news now shows most households are
cutting back on dining out 51 percent
are looking at flyers for bargains and
nearly half are putting off new
discretionary purchases like clothing
sandy is a personal finance author
that's helped her family move fast to
cut back where they can and selling
items they're not using for extra cash
collecting loyalty points has also
helped them pay for baby items and the
daily sticker shock she's feeling at the
pumps has her ready to make the switch
to an electric vehicle we might expedite
our goal because the gas prices are
rising so quickly
inflation chips away at affordability
for struggling households it may mean
some bills won't get paid right away or
the debt load gets bigger others won't
be able to save as much so how to
strategize well if you can one move may
be to try boosting your income ask your
employer for a raise reveal your budget
and find ways to trim expenses
have a look at old credit card
statements have a look at old bank
statements what is popping up and put
your money to work if you know you won't
need it in the next little while you can
invest in risk insulated bonds or stocks
to hedge against inflation
if you're saving for retirement for
example 20 30 40 years now is a great
time to get in yes it's definitely been
a struggle because i'm living on 70
percent of my normal income we
review our monthly budget together
to ensure that we
are
cash flow positive month to month this
new economic reality may lead to better
financial habits to last a lifetime ann
gaviola global news
toronto
next the first images of the mystery at
the center of our galaxy
[Music]
there is still so much we don't know
about the universe but now we have at
least a glimpse at what lies at the
heart of our galaxy the milky way and as
mike drollay explains the effort it took
to get the image is out of this world
this wasn't just any picture for
astronomers it's the picture the first
direct
image
of the gentle giant in the center of our
galaxy sagittarius a star
to put the discovery in context it was
announced in seven countries
simultaneously this is the first image
so this is what they unveiled and while
we can't actually see a black hole we
can see the glowing gas around it and
given time and more pictures they'll be
able to analyze how it's evolving now
which star wars apparently didn't get
right get a poetic license shall we say
the massive milky way galaxy has over
100 billion stars one of which is our
sun so seeing into the middle of it all
has proven to be difficult still
scientists have long believed if they
could they'd find a black hole for me
personally
i met it 20 years ago and have loved it
and tried to understand it since
but until now
we didn't have the direct picture
confirming that sanjay starr was indeed
a black hole they took the picture using
the event horizon telescope which is
actually 11 telescopes scattered around
the world and when synced up they create
a virtual telescope dish as large as the
earth itself to say it's complicated
would be underselling it you've got to
look through the plane of our galaxy and
there's an awful lot of stuff between us
and the center of the galaxy stars dust
gas planets you name it it's there and
to be able to tease out the details of
the supermassive black hole you have to
get rid of literally everything in the
pathway and that's why the observation
the observational analysis took the
better part of three years three years
to get one image but considering it's at
the heart of the galaxy well worth the
wait
mike drew like global news toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is this nighttime view of
calgary thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you